he's lynn swann former Steeler wide
receiver hall-of-famer USC athletic
director and what are you 67 yes
yeah you look pretty good I'm trying to
hide no yeah trying to keep trying to
stay young ya know when's the last time
you caught a pass ah boy standing on the
sidelines maybe one overthrown older in
practice and just kind of grabbed it but
fortunately we haven't had a lot of
those well I was gonna ask you that you
guys aren't ranked you know preseason
poll you're not ranked right what do you
think the biggest reason why USC
football is not USC football volt well I
think it's it's a process a lot of
coaching changes early on I think most
people realize it takes a while to get
there if you haven't had good recruiting
years so you got to build it up and then
you've got to find the players to fit
your system in that same in that same
process so I think that's part of it
the the additional coaching changes
don't help but I think clay Helton will
provide some stability yes last year was
a very disappointing year 5 & 7 no one's
happy with that but sometimes I think
emotionally and mentally you get to a
place and you think you've arrived you
know you you haven't won the pac-12
championship but you're back into a
great Rose Bowl game and you play and
all of a sudden everybody's hopes are up
there's oh man that looks like our USC
football team or the dramatic win over
Penn State then you come back and you
win the pac-12 championship and
everything seems to be going up and you
start feeling really good about it right
and you kind of move along and that
sense of urgency doesn't kind of take
place and there are some things that
need to change and they don't change and
so you have a very disappointing season
I think that clay understands that I
think he's brought back that sense of
urgency uh he's increased the intensity
of everything they're doing on the
football field and I think the coaches
changes have been good so let me ask you
a question look it probably won't know
the answer to it I don't expect you to
how many coaching changes how many
different personnel changes did USC
making football this year well I know
you had Kliff Kingsbury for a little
while for a moment yeah okay um I
no how many 18 why do you need to make
18 change are you talking about making
changes subtle changes big changes
offensive coordinators different coaches
that come in and looking what's doing
and he wanted to upgrade what he was
doing I think Graham as our offensive
coordinator coming in helps her often
it's a great deal because instead of
using a system that three different head
coaches at one time USC kind of
collaborated on he simplify things he
got rid of all the old terminology that
was created by three different coaches
and he brings in a simplified
terminology for the quarterbacks and
receivers two offensive line and so it
gets everybody on the same page what
does that allow you to do lost everybody
to be athletes not to overthink what
you're doing I think that was hugely
important yeah explain the Kliff
Kingsbury thing why was that just a
cameo there did he have business cards
already made up with hey you have to ask
cliff that question up and up until the
time cliff left everything I heard and
from cliff was that he intended to stay
and then it's Christmas it's the
holidays
you know things were going back and
forth this agents calling I'm calling
the head coach he says no he's staying
it cetera et cetera and so I call cliff
on the phone and cliff was at the
airport going to Arizona
I'm just within New York okay yeah then
coming through Arizona okay and so yeah
you look it it's it's kind of a no-win
situation you're trying to get the best
coach best coaching staffs you can have
right yeah you signed someone they say
they want to come if it'll fit but for a
college to give a reputation that you
have a coordinator but you're gonna
block him from leaving to go to the NFL
yeah hmm you know who's gonna come there
yeah yeah yeah yeah it let's let's be
honest if you're not a head coach and
you want to be a head coach you know
there's gonna be a couple of moves in
your life maybe you're more than just a
couple and if you don't have the ability
to move when an opportunity presents
itself
what do you gonna do
when you first get that call with the
academic scandal there within the
athletic department do you get a phone
call or does somebody come to your
office and say sit down Lynne I got
something to say to you you know I have
a fault I got a phone call from someone
internal at USC and said you're gonna
you're gonna read about this you're
gonna hear about this here's what's
going on and I think it's it's easy to
say that the entire athletic department
you know the university itself was in
shock but do you how do you process that
because like you didn't have a whiff of
any of this well like you know it look
who did yeah I mean you look around the
country you look at every school that's
involved and and it ask yourself okay
who at what school found this out and
the answer no one yeah
it only was found out because someone
was caught for something else and
thought he could help himself by turning
evidence in this particular area I'm
glad he did the problem is seen the
light hits it and now we have an
opportunity to fix it so it doesn't
happen again
and that's what you work on is there a
magic win total for clay Helton this
year for you for clay Helton well Dan
you know I I won't go there on that one
I mean I think you know we judge our
coaches on the variety of things
certainly we want to win and want to be
at the top but clay is doing a great job
motivating and helping these young kids
have a productive three four years at
USC working towards their college
degrees we had 19 players on our team
last year that wore a graduation patch
which means they're graduating by the
end of that semester or have already
graduated so very proud of that and we
want to move it forward so I don't look
at this as well you've got to win 11
games you've got to be undefeated you've
got to do this you know and our goals
remain the same do we want to be at the
top absolutely where does that begin
yeah it's weird to see USC as an
underdog story
mm-hmm but you guys are an underdog
story this year she got a great
quarterback I think your wide receivers
are going to
potentially could be great great grouper
y-you see yes really really talented but
you're you're gonna play the underdog
role it feels like we have a tough
schedule yeah you know but you know
that's okay I mean it's just a couple
years ago that you know one of our big
rivals obviously Notre Dame was having
the same kinds of issues made changes
and they've had a couple of good years
back to back you know we look to improve
and be better and we look for this team
to to show better
he's Lynn Swann the former Steeler Hall
of Famer and of course USC athletic
director where were you on the Franco
Harris Immaculate reception I was at USC
yeah what did you think at that time
when you were watching that unfold gonna
be tough for a wide receiver the beat
and Immaculate reception yeah you're
catching the Superbowl better than
Franco's there's a statue of Franco
regardless of what I might say or feel
or think there's the evidence right
there there's a statue of George
Washington and Franklin Harris and the
Immaculate reception and you lived up to
your name
you know we're talking about David Stern
he was that's who he was Usain Bolt's
you were Lynn Swann
where'd that athleticism come from well
you took ballet too didn't you well my
mom and dad didn't think I'd be a great
athlete and so when that was young and
being the youngest of three kids you
know my mom kind of wanted to keep me
close and so my mom and in the fourth
grade decided I should take dance
lessons little boy hyper kid running
around all the time that kind of thing
so she thought this would take the edge
off I think so I enrolled les Williams
dance studio in San Mateo California are
you the only boy in there ah
no there were two boys in the class okay
and there were 14 girls not bad so it
was it was a tap class and so it was tap
dancing I started out with tap dancing
and and then I got into jazz I did
summer plays musicals I did West Side
Story you know in summertime sent me to
a recreation department
u.s. see I would dance I danced in
senior projects looking for male dancers
to be in in the class I got involved
with the Pittsburgh Ballet Theatre and
setting up on the board of directors and
setting up scholarships so there was
dancing dancing in my whole life and so
that was it just kind of moved it along
who you considered the best NFL
quarterback yeah
the best well you know look I guess I'm
partial people will say I'm a little bit
prejudiced on this one you know I I
would I would like to say Ben
Roethlisberger is because I'm a
Pittsburgh Steeler about all time but I
have to say Tom Brady okay and and Tom
Brady did go to my high school at Serra
High School in San Mateo you know I've
seen them in college when I covered
college football for Brady have a statue
at your high school no he doesn't have a
statute okay OC went there Bakhtiari
plays for Green Bay it was there a Greg
Jeffrey's was there John Robinson the
coach knows that Sarah high school so if
we fact you know for a small all-boys
Catholic High School we've got some
pretty decent athletes there what's your
favorite Terry Bradshaw story off the
field that I've told before well yeah
look I've got I've got the story about
Terry okay okay and this is true and
it's kind of it's it's kind of at my
expense to a certain degree but it kind
of tells you a little bit about Terry's
growth as a quarterback because you know
Chuck really didn't want to throw the
ball that much and so we're getting
ready for Super Bowl 13 against the
Cowboys and I looked at film and I saw
how the safeties responded for a quick
pass and quarterback makes a three-step
drop
you know the safeties see that they come
charging up looking for the pass to with
ever receiver right so I thought we
could take advantage of it by running a
slant pattern all right then Terry has
to pump fake it and then you turn the
slant
and to a skinny pulse when the Safety's
come charging up yeah you know passing
that train by the time they react to it
you already buy them and so Tom Moore
who is our receiver coach at the time we
put it in and it looked good worked well
at practice so it's called 42 I take off
and that's my side I'm the right side
receiver John Stallworth Hall of Fame
wide receiver on the left side if we
were to call it to John it would be 43
so we get in the perfect situation in
the game to call that play and i'm all
hyped up because i put the play in it's
the Super Bowl if it's cowboys again
Terry looks at me and he kind of
chuckles you've seen him do that
chuckling okay hello the good ol boy
kind of laughs and his shoulders in the
whole thing yeah I'm going in Terry look
somebody goes full left split 43 I take
uh-oh 43 he calls it to John run to play
it's executed perfectly John scores a
touchdown I'm running down the field
going yeah you know you tell these
stories about a Bradshaw and you might
recall the story where was supposedly
Montana well I wasn't there so this
supposedly was in the hello and the
Superbowl game and we sold John Candy so
John Candy tells a story and calms
people down than the hello and he leads
him down and makes a great play I think
for Terry that moment was a moment of
realization for him that he kind of had
this under control
and he knew what he was doing he ends up
you know being the MVP of that game and
that's our third Super Bowl and his
first MVP Frankel was first I was
seconded so it and and so it's it's a
good story you kind of laugh at it you
know I laugh at myself about it you know
but it's just a good story about Terry
in the moment you know is actually in
control he knows exactly what he's doing
I know that we talked about Aaron Donald
now and you know you have people who
cover this league and have covered this
league for a long time saying he might
be already the greatest interior
defensive lineman in history and I went
man I saw me
like there's a few hmm and it's a short
list but mean chill green was he was he
was nasty I mean he lived up to his name
he was tough like his dad stuff that you
would get it suspended like he'd spit on
somebody well Joe is not the guy guy he
would spit on but he grabbed your helm I
Spit on somebody I don't recall him
spitting anybody but he might he would
grab your helmet and punch you in the
belly one day three times about holding
him but you know who scared me more Mel
Blount oh no it looks like he could
still play now Mel Mel looks like he
should be a linebacker and he's six like
at the defensive back that big was
unheard of cornerback oh man yeah I mean
he he could be a linebacker well I mean
you guys debate a lot of different
issues never hit you who Mel yeah no
okay you know he had John Stallworth
John golden went against him every day
on the other side oh so he kind of play
him a little bit more no but yo you know
Mel Mel was Mel's a warrior and he way
after you know it's you guys debate a
lot of different things you talk about
the greatest player the greatest player
of all time yeah how do you do that in a
game that continues to evolve yeah we
can do it with quarterbacks and you can
do quarterbacks in their era I'm not
sure you can I mean because look at how
the game has changed your rules have
changed look at what you're asking to do
in terms of throwing the ball in the
passing game and the evolution of the
passion game look at the technology look
at the quarterbacks have you know
devices in the helmet we're in the call
the place Bart Starr never had that when
he was playing look at how the game has
changed from the emphasis of the running
back look at the great athletes you not
have across the board you got real
athletes you know since the days of
Lawrence Taylor playing outside
linebackers linebacker who runs as fast
as a as a running back and can run you
down from behind so you look at all
these changes I think the best at least
from my standpoint the best I could do
in trying to figure out who's the best
figure who's the best of a decade and
maybe the decade isn't from the 70s to
the 80s maybe
decade is from 75 to 85 because the rule
changes and what happened in the league
but it's Jerry Rice the greatest
receiver of all time well you guys were
always pointing out welcome Joe Montana
Steve Young I tell them I tell this
story
now we're gonna really put it out there
okay I tell this story you know look
Jerry Rice had these guys who were so
accurate throwing the ball in your
mind's eye close your eyes and see Jerry
Rice catching a pass he's catching it
right here right here yards have to
catch I mean he could have been born
with no arms and still caught a thousand
passes from his quarterback you know
John and I had Terry Bradshaw we're
diving so I think Jerry Rice is a
phenomenal receiver you know uh Beckham
I think has great skill do you think
you're better than Jerry Rice do I think
I'm better every time I take the field I
think I'm going to get it done and
that's the right answer
yeah I don't compete against Jerry Rice
I compete against my canes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
swanny is great to see you good luck you
got you you know got a lot on your plate
there we have a lot on our plate but
it's it's an opportunity to improve it
to give it better to do the right things
you know I worked a lot of years with
Big Brothers and Big Sisters of America
mentoring kids was the National Board
Chairman you know my goal is to do it
right for the athletes there if we're
not doing it right for the
student-athletes we're in the wrong
place he's Lynn Swann the Hall of Famer
and athletic director at USC for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]